the UK unemployment rate currently
stands at just 3.7 percent the
unemployment rate for 16 to 24 year olds
is 10.8 percent while the inactivity
rate that's those not in education
employment or training stands at 38.2
percent while the charity movement to
work was set up to tackle that State of
Affairs it seeks to help young people
not currently in education employment or
training step onto the career ladder by
working with UK employers to provide
quality jobs training and work placement
opportunities today marks its 10th
anniversary and it's hosting a CEO
conference to get more companies to
support its work well joining me now is
the Charity's new chair Charles Woodburn
who is of course also chief executive of
BAE Systems Charles very good morning to
you why do you think inactivity levels
are so high for this group
well it's been quite a challenging
period in and
um as you said it is uh something that
we as businesses feel very strongly
about and anything we can do to help get
people uh into uh workplaces give them
the placement opportunities which then
hopefully will lead to successful
outcomes uh we as a company have been
one of the founding members of movement
to work I personally have been involved
since 2017 and we've seen the people
that have come through movement to work
I meet them as I go around our UK
businesses and see how well they're
doing they flourish with us they come in
typically for a placement uh that
becomes a bridge into an apprenticeship
and then from an apprenticeship into the
workplace and high quality you know
long-term employment uh you know awaits
at the end of it so we have had a very
strong experience with movement to work
a very positive experience and uh you
know part of the reason I feel so
passionate about it is that I want to
make sure that other companies
understand that there is an answer to
some of these Channel challenges that
these young people are facing are
employers doing a good enough job in
engaging with youth employment programs
well I think there's quite a variety of
them and we certainly think that
movement to work uh Stands Tall within
that uh movement to work has actually
offered 160 000 opportunities since it
was founded uh 10 years ago and uh more
than half of those have led to
successful outcomes uh so you know
that's a very large number of people
that have that have used the opportunity
and we're very keen to make sure that
you know other companies are aware of
the success of movement to work uh aware
of the program the fact that uh it
doesn't cost anything to join movement
to work uh you know we support the young
people they get
um their transport and their lunches
paid for when they do a placement with
us and really to try and reduce the
barriers that some of these young people
face to find their way into a workplace
and ultimately a high quality long-term
employment at the end of it I mean your
company BAE Systems requires heavily on
very very highly skilled workers kind of
someone on a work placement really add
much value can can they pick up a lot in
a short space of time
well I think that the evidence is there
I mean we as a company through movement
to work uh have had 700 placements uh in
the last 10 years we're offering another
100 this year and as I've said already
as I go around our businesses I quite
often meet people that are very proud to
say that they started on a movement to
work placement and you know whilst the
placement itself is really a bridge into
an apprenticeship uh you know I always
think the placements they allow us as a
company to see you know how people work
in the place of work but equally they
allow those who are enjoying the
placement to see what we are like as an
employer and make a much more educated
decision so it is a you know first step
on a pathway uh but coming into our
Apprentice programs and as you know we
have a you know very strong Apprentice
program here in the UK we've increased
our Apprentice numbers but getting onto
an apprentice program then really is
then uh you know the first step or the
second step after the placement into
long-term employment
now as we speak the prime minister is
giving a speech on uh how he wants
people to carry on studying maths right
up until the age of 18. do you think
that's a good idea
well from our perspective you know we're
an engineering uh company uh at its
heart and uh stem or these numeracy
skills are indeed uh very important for
us so you know we firmly uh would
support uh you know more numeracy and a
higher standard coming out of uh of our
schools
is the education system in this country
equipping young people sufficiently for
the kind of careers that the modern
economy is providing them with
but I think
there has been in the last
um you know handful of years I think a
more of an appreciation of what uh
apprenticeships can really offer and I
think that we've been as a company
trying to make sure that people
understand that there's always been this
sort of view at school age uh that that
you know The Graduate route was was in a
sense the only way into Quality
Employment and apprenticeships offer an
incredibly strong alternative
particularly at a time of cost of living
you know crises and some of the
challenges of inflation where you can
come into the work workplace
um you know in many cases people can
come through an apprenticeship and
indeed get a degree at the end of it not
all of them will will do that but
without debt and then um you know with
it with a job at the end of it and I
think that the more we can do as
employers to sort of demonstrate that
that is a not only just an alternative
but a very good alternative to the
standard graduate track I think it
behooves all of us to make sure or that
you know young people see the importance
of that see the significance of it and I
think you know for us as a company we do
a very good job in the places that are
close to our uh you know large centers
of employment but I think nationally
there's more we can do to raise the
profile of apprenticeships
and Charles well we have you uh there's
been a lot of talk in the recent past
about potentially the defense sector
being deprived of capital because some
investors won't invest on ESG grounds do
you feel that the war in Ukraine has
shifted sentiment among investors
towards the defense sector
I think it's fair to say in that it is
Shifting
um you know there is still some way to
go we've always maintained that you know
ESG and ESG considerations are important
but in all of that requires the
foundation of defense and security and
without defense and security
um it's you know it's very hard to you
know give any uh
um credibility to the other aspects of
ESG so obviously I mean unfortunately
due to the uh conflict uh here in Europe
in the brutal invasion of Ukraine you
know I think that the the sort of the
the case for defense and security you
know has been uh more clearly made I
think you know within all of that it's
then important for us to show as an
employer the steps that we're taking to
be a good place to work that we look
after the environment The Net Zero
things that we're doing so they're all
important considerations but as a
foundation defense and security you know
has to be what modern democracies
freedom of speech all the things that we
take for granted are based upon
all right Charles we have to leave it
there really good to see you this
morning and best of luck with the events
thank you
thanks very much